so you're charles lucky luciano at the
end of the 1930s you're a brutal
gangster a pimp a racketeer a murderer
and the father of modern day organized
crime
lucky luciano was the father of
organized crime here in america before
him mob crime was just crime it didn't
become organized until lucky luciano
came along to get to the top you had
your own mafia boss executed and you
were the most feared man to walk the
streets of new york city but there was
only one problem you're in jail
in 1936 lucky luciano had been caught
tried and found guilty of forced
prostitution the sentence 30 to 50 years
in jail
for a few years you tried running your
mafia out of jail but things were tough
it seemed like there was nothing for you
to do but wait and hope for an early
parole that will probably never come but
then just three years later you come
across some luck once more world war ii
hits europe and chaos breaks out across
the globe
suddenly you're presented with a once in
a lifetime opportunity you see america
quickly joined the side of the allies
like england and france which meant the
us was fair game for attacks from the
germans and one of america's most
valuable most vulnerable points of
attack from german submarines was the
new york harbor the same harbor america
was using to ship millions of tons of
food equipment tools and weapons to
london
take out the harbor and wipe out most of
the allies supplies in europe so every
spy and agent in the city was on higher
alerts trying to figure out whether the
germans were planning attacks or if they
had spies on the docks which was great
for the mafia because you had complete
control over those ducks your crime
family was in charge of the dock workers
union and with the came full control of
anything and everything that was
happening there and what do you know the
us government came crawling right back
to lucky luciano to help protect the
vital new york harbor and what resulted
was one of the most unexpected
partnerships of world war ii and in the
history of organized crime a secret
partnership between the us military and
america's public enemy number one lucky
luciano and the italian american mafia
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
charles lucky luciano was an unlikely
war hero charles had arrived in the us
as a child in 1907. settling in new york
city he quickly got involved in all
sorts of illegal low-level mafia hustles
stealing fighting in the streets and
threatening his schoolmates so they gave
up their lunch money you know regular
poor kid in the early 1900s new york
city kind of stuff and once prohibition
hit the us in 1920 you upped your game
instead of petty theft and street brawls
you switched to bootlegging smuggling
illegal alcohol
they became involved in prostitution
rings extortion blackmail and
bootlegging in fact lucky luciano very
quickly became one of the big six in
bootlegging on the east coast
while also taking over most of the
operations in the city for the world's
oldest profession wink wink you were
doing so well for yourself that near the
end of the 20s you had a much grander
vision for power and prestige at the
time the mafia more than half of which
was sicilian like you was completely
unorganized different families were
fighting with each other and instead of
working together to get richer and more
powerful the fighting between mafias was
only making all of you weaker a house
divided cannot stand so you decide to
end the fighting once and for all
1931 lucky luciano facilitated the
killing of the two mob bosses in new
york joe massaria and mr maranzano with
his rivals removed luciano became new
york's top mob boss so after a few
assassinations you brought the other
four big mafia families in new york
together to create a pact a cartel where
each family will get their own parts of
the cities to rule over and to make sure
that they crush all the other existing
new york crime families at the time so
they wouldn't have to put up with any
competition these five families would
later grow to dominate and completely
control new york and would become known
as simply the five families
together each of the five families were
referred to by their most famous ruling
godfather bonano colombo gambino
genovese and lucasy but lucky's most
defining moment was the creation of the
commission
a national governing body where all the
major mafia families in the us would
come together where all the big
decisions and new rules were all come
down to a vote with each family having
one vote bringing order to chaos and
with the commission formed and the rules
set the american mafia became custom
designed from the ground up to
efficiently plunder the us and it was
all possible because of lucky luciano
who became the boss of bosses the amount
of power you wielded was unmatched no
one in the city could touch you but then
lucky luciano was arrested you have
become public enemy number one and the
nypd and politicians were gonna make an
example of you so you started your 30 to
50 year stint in dannemora a jail so
brutal and god forsaken that it was
known as little siberia
but while you sat in prison with little
hope of seeing freedom ever again the
germans started infiltrating america
lucky luciano became the boss of bosses
for the mafia because of his skills to
rise to the top of his industry he had
to have negotiation skills leadership
skills and be a quick thinker and
believe it or not all those skills are
learnable and vital for whatever
business you're in if only there was a
platform to learn all these skills and
much more all in one place that's where
skillshare comes in skillshare is an
online learning community where people
from all over the world can rediscover
their love for learning whether you want
to hone your existing skills try
something new or completely change the
course of your life skillshare has a
huge variety of classes to appeal to
anyone there are no annoying ads no
interruptions to your classes and an
ever growing list of premium classes
which means you get unlimited access to
amazing topics like this class taught by
michael trineau on the entrepreneurship
hustle and how to turn your business
plans into successes or this class on
inclusive ux designing websites for
everyone it has more than 4 300 students
and is taught by regina alberts a class
where you can learn a skill that earns a
base pay of around 115 000 a year an
income bracket that you could get into
by starting your learning journey on
skillshare today's world rewards
competence people who are great at what
they do whether they're a mafia boss
entrepreneur or freelancer so if you
want to up your competence sign up for
skillshare right now by clicking the
link in the description the first 1 000
of my subscribers to do that will also
get a one month free trial so you can
start exploring what skillshare has to
offer right now
pause the video and click the link below
to join now thanks to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
around the same time you were
languishing in little siberia a group of
german spies known only as the duquesne
spy ring had arrived on american soil
they weren't the only german agents to
infiltrate the us but they were by far
the most dangerous the group was led by
a veteran spy friedrich dukanes and
their mission locate and destroy as many
vital american infrastructure sites as
possible but before they could implement
their plans most of them were caught but
this revelation only made us officials
more paranoid on january 2nd 1942 33
members of the duquesne spy ring were
sentenced to a collective 300 years in
jail police have found maps and pictures
of industrial plants information about a
new bomb the us was making and hundreds
of notes on how to start fires to burn
down infrastructure if these 33 spies
had gotten this close who's to say they
were the only ones
for all the us authorities knew there
could be hundreds of spies crawling
across new york alone just waiting to
cause chaos
predicting this fear you as lucky
luciano set in motion the most daring
and rewarding plan of your life
[Music]
the u.s joined world war ii in december
1941. as soon as the announcement was
made american ships became a target in
the first few months after joining
german u-boats or submarines were
seeking 80 ships a month no one in the
military or government could figure out
how the germans knew where the ships
were and when to attack naturally they
assumed it had to be spies so the navy
and military sent its people to the new
york docks their job figure out where
the germans were getting their
information from and identify the
traders who were giving it to them with
italy being controlled by a fascist
government and most of the dock workers
being italian there must have been
someone feeding the germans information
simple enough right except like we
mentioned earlier lucky luciano had
control of the docks and thanks to the
mafia's threat of violence against rats
not a single worker said a word the
government was frustrated they needed to
know how to stop the germans from
destroying their ships and you were the
only ones standing in their way but that
didn't bother you much because you had
seen a way out a way to get free from
your doomed jail sentence all you had to
do was make the us government realize
just how much they needed you
on february 9 1942 something happened
that pushed the government over the edge
the uss normandy a french cruise ship
turned into a troop carrier caught fire
while docked in the harbor the paper
said it was an accident a worker's torch
had made too many sparks or something
along those lines but everyone knew the
truth it was arson whether it had been
the germans or the mafia's own men was
irrelevant you just needed the
authorities to believe it had been your
people so you made a crazy claim that it
was your men they torched the normandy
on your orders albert figures that if
something could happen to the normandy
that would make everybody crap in their
pants it was a great idea
so i sent back white to albert to handle
it a couple of days later i heard on the
radio where the normandy was on fire and
it didn't look like they could save her
they got them out but he really done a
job
if the us government wanted to get back
control of the docks they would have to
go through you unwilling to deal with
america's public enemy number one the
police first went to your guy in the
docks joseph sucks lonza he agreed to
try to get information and cooperation
out of the dock workers and operation
underworld officially began but the
workers were still suspicious if the
orders didn't come directly from luciano
they would be in danger of getting
killed or beat up if he found out they
ratted eventually getting nowhere on his
own sox lanza admitted he would need
your permission
[Music]
and so in may 1942 a group of lawyers
police officers naval officers and
mobsters headed for little siberia it
was time to make a deal with the devil
himself
[Music]
even after six years of riding in jail
use the weirded absolute power over the
new york docks after what the us
government had thought been your little
fireworks show on the uss normandy you
were hated now more than ever by the
navy and naval officers but that didn't
matter they needed you and even if they
promised you wouldn't get any special
treatment for helping them you knew your
chance have finally come
lieutenant hafenden from the new york
naval office was in charge of operation
underworld and he held most of the
negotiation power without a single
promise to let you out early or make
your life easier hafende never expected
you to agree to help but you did anyways
on mino sadam you were playing the long
game
so you set out the word there was to be
no more burning of ships no more riding
and the dock workers had to give new
york authorities any information they
needed about potential german activity
around the harbor the order was
immediately obeyed
you didn't need the authorities to agree
to a deal right away you just needed to
get your foot in the door to open up the
dialogue and build some trust not long
after helping them at the docks you got
one of the things you wanted you were
transferred from little siberia to great
meadow prison which like its flowery
name suggests was one of the easiest
growing prisons in the u.s
[Music]
while america's biggest worry was a ship
seeking faster than it could make new
ones that people in sicily were having
problems of their own for years italian
dictator benito mussolini have been
trying to get control of the island of
sicily when he took over italy in 1922
he hated the idea that any power other
than fascism could control italy which
was a problem for sicily where most of
the island was run by the mafia so
mussolini sent soldiers to torture and
kill every mafia boss and member they
could get their hands on those that
didn't die in the hands of mussolini's
army went into hiding waiting for the
chance to fight back and in 1943 that
chance arrived an opportunity was about
to come luciano's way
[Music]
lucky luciano had been born
the u.s navy was planning to invade
sicily hoping it would serve as a
gateway into the rest of europe the only
issue was they have very little time and
even less information to successfully
take over sicily they would need
contacts on the ground maps of the
island and surrounding waters a clear
picture of the terrain they were going
to be fighting on and with no time to
waste the navy turned to sicilian
immigrants for help but just like the
dock workers they wouldn't cooperate
without the mafia's permission so the
group of lawyers mobsters naval officers
and policemen once again came crawling
back to lucky luciano just as expected
this time they wanted you to get the
sicilians to share vital intel and
contacts in sicily with the navy again
they emphasized over and over again that
you would get nothing from the deal but
again by now you already had your hooks
in this would be a great chance to build
both more trust in the us governments
and help the mafia take back control of
sicily 2 in the process
so you gave the orders again cooperate
with the navy under the orders of lucky
luciano
and as expected intel from hundreds of
sicilians suddenly came flooding in by
the time operation husky was launched
and us troops landed on the beaches of
sicily on july 10 1943 the u.s navy had
every piece of intel about the island
they could have ever wanted maps of the
beaches maps of the towns names of the
mafia bosses who will help them once
they arrived detailed information about
the water surrounding the island and
cooperation with dozens of sicilian
american mafia members who wanted to
make the trip to sicily to help
lucky came up with a plant that i
thought was pretty wild
he wanted to join up with the invading
army
operation husky resulted in the biggest
beach landing in us history at the time
the mafia and sicily hated the fascist
government about as much as the american
troops did and with full cooperation of
most of the island it didn't take long
for american troops to start making
progress on the very first day several
navy lieutenants with the help of the
mafia were able to capture the
headquarters of the italian naval
command on the island inside they found
maps of minefields in the ocean around
italy and europe among other documents
that were priceless to the us naval
intelligence armed with insight
information the us military secured the
entire western side of the island just
two weeks after landing they were making
fast progress and this huge military
success was all thanks to america's
public enemy number one and back in the
u.s it was time for the government to
pay his dues
[Music]
as lucky luciano you were convinced that
you were the man who won the war without
you the us would have never conquered
sicily or italy without you they would
have been defeated within days of
arriving on the island you had done the
government an enormous favor by helping
them win the war and now it was time for
them to show you their gratitude health
from the mafia never came without a
price and it was america's time to pay
up at first the notion of letting one of
america's most notorious mobsters walk
free was unthinkable it was 1945 the war
was closely being won but there was no
way they were going to give you credit
for winning it then the war ended
it was a sweet victory for the allies
and a crushing defeat for the axis
powers the u.s government was high on
its success as the superpower of the
world and lucky luciano's time had
finally come
america's number one criminal the father
of organized crime as we know it had his
jail time commuted the only condition
luciano had to be deported back to his
homeland and never set foot in the u.s
again not a bad trade when the
alternative was life in prison so in
1946 charles lucky luciano got lucky one
last time he boarded a ship back to
italy as a free man and if the
government thought sending him away
would keep him out of trouble they were
sadly mistaken with the mafia taking
back power in sicily luciano got right
back into business as soon as he arrived
soon lucky luciano was back in business
with sicily now back under mob control
he massively strengthened his criminal
links across the atlantic and expanded
the influence of the new york mafia
lucky luciano would spend the rest of
his life in his beloved homeland dying
of a heart attack in 1962 in operation
underworld it was kept a secret for
decades until the mid 70s when the
report was finally released and the
world came to learn about one of the
strangest government collaborations in
u.s history
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video today if you're new here we make
business documentaries just like this
one every single week on the most
provocative stuff in the world of money
power war and crime just like this video
so click that subscribe button and the
join button below if you want more day
in the life kind of stuff like
all this i'm in london right now by the
way you can follow me on instagram at
jaketrend.io that's going to wrap it up
keep sharpening out mine stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign